[Music]
as we remember the life of john lewis
we were struck by one touching reading
in particular from yesterday's funeral
beyond this place of wrath and tears
looms but the horror of the shade
and yet menace of the years
finds and shall find me unafraid
that was tybree faw a young friend of
the late congressman
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller spoke with tybree after
the service and she joins us
from outside the historic ebenezer
baptist church in atlanta where the
funeral took place michelle
good morning once again good morning and
despite
all of the celebrity in that sanctuary
yesterday the politicians the civil
rights icons
it was a 12 year old boy from tennessee
that stole the show in front of american
presidents
and john lewis's closest loved ones it
was one of the congressman's youngest
admirers who contributed to one of the
day's most
memorable moments in the fellow clutches
of circumstance
i have not went nor cried aloud
twelve-year-old tybree fah helped
eulogize the civil rights icon by
reading what he said to be
lewis's favorite poem i'm the master of
my fate
[Music]
i'm the captain of my soul
john lewis was my hero my friend let's
honor him by getting in good trouble
thaw first met louis when he was only 10
years old
in tennessee he was in selma alabama
commemorating the anniversary of bloody
sunday
you met him at selma tell me how that
meeting went
well it was really emotional because you
know i met
somebody that i really cared about
that impromptu meeting on the streets of
alabama quickly evolved into a
friendship with faw attending a number
of protests and events
alongside lewis we cannot give up now
including his final walk across the
edmond pettus bridge
in march of this year when did you find
out he passed away
my grandma called me and said he died
how was that for you
what have you lost in losing him
i just lost a friend and he did all he
can
he fulfilled his purpose
he did what he did did he charge you
to pick up the mantle he passed down his
legacy and now what do you do with it
i want to make it greater and better for
everybody
and tybre's two grandmothers helped
raise him along with a single mom they
fostered his interest
in history of taking them all over this
country to historical sites
including the edmund pettus bridge where
he met the late congressman
this is a budding young young
environmentalist and i'm sure we'll be
seeing
more of him to come gail oh michelle we
have not heard the last of ty i talked
to his grandmother lauren yesterday i
know you did too and she said this to me
when your babies speak up listen to them
listen to them
and let them do it and let them what did
she say exactly she said
listen to them and take them up on it as
you pointed out they took him to the
bridge in selma where he got to meet
john lewis because he called john lewis
when he was nine
and said i want to come and shake your
hand and they took him there so he could
do that
so i think she's onto something listen
to your babies this is a little kid who
was a history buff
who's loved history since he was a
little boy i love everything about this
little guy
me too yeah
and you got to meet him he's on the same
stage with three living presidents at
something